did you just come in old broad  yikes Wednesday's episode of The View  didn't exactly get off to a smooth start  with Whoopi Goldberg clapping back at  what seemed to be a Heckler in the  audience  all right all right  it's a very happy birthday from crowd  yeah so anybody wondering about the did  you just call me an old broad  whoopee and the rest of the panel took  it in stride using the moment as an  opportunity to look at the positives he  said yo bro  oh  it's Wednesday it's Wednesday and I am  an old broad and happy about  what's the alternative that's the  alternative yeah the alternative is not  attractive to any of them we all want to  be all brought in all dudes  now this isn't the first time that  Whoopi has handled Rowdy audience  members back in October hecklers went  after guest Ted Cruz and Whoopi quickly  sent them packing guys  ladies ladies excuse us let us do our  job let us do our job we hear what you  have to say but you gotta go